they have a different set of rules down
there you have to be extra careful no oh
be small like this
first time I heard about the Emmett Till
event I was in elementary school oh look
like a movie star what
it's one of those stories that if you're
black you've heard about it I want to
talk to you about that boy most of us
would not know who Emmett Till was if it
weren't for me the whole world has to
see what happened to my son Mamie was
very aware and intentional about the
power of the image to really bring
awareness that would result in a level
of change and activism and to Galvanize
people into doing something
Orion exists to give a platform to the
Myriad of filmmakers like chinoya that
have something to contribute to the
Cinematic Canon of American film and I'm
really really committed to making movies
not just by us but for us we put
Emmett's story in his proper context and
history to understand how his story
sparked the American Civil Rights
Movement we get to see how many fights
for justice if something is happening to
one of us it is happening to all of us
and we witness her coming to a
particular kind of power and to be the
progenitor of the Civil Rights Movement
those pictures of your son change
people's lives Mimi turned tragedy into
purpose which is why we sit here today
this story needs to be told in a way
that is humanizing empowering and that
is necessary there will be no physical
violence against black people on screen
because I'm not interested in relishing
in that kind a physical trauma we're
going to begin and end in a place of joy
you just be beeped when you should have
bopped
Mimi was a catalyst for change she
affected millions of lives the better
made me tell nobody is a hero
the lynching of my son has shown me that
what happens to any of us anywhere in
the world
us all
foreign